bryce wilson who's coming off a solid
start jeff last time out against the
cubs yeah threw five innings against the
cubs only one strikeout but got
a lot of quick outs and you see that
he's been great here at truiss park in
three career home starts
all depends on what thermometer you're
looking at i think yep
1-1
ground ball to the left side riley
ranges to his left nice pickup wings its
sidearm to first and there's the first
down of the game we'll keep an eye on
that over the course of the afternoon
there's a fastball up and calhoun drives
it to right it's high off the wall
acuna does a nice job playing that
bounce off the bricks and it's a long
single for coal
[Applause]
popped up left side riley gives a peek
over by the arizona dugout he's gonna
have room on the track and escobar's
retired two outs
off the middle but into the shift dansby
is there wins the race to the bag and
bryce wilson gets two ground ball outs
in a scoreless top of the first
right-hander zach gallon his third start
since coming off that hairline fracture
in his right forearm and looking for win
number one gallon who's averaging more
than a strikeout per inning
and where did that get hopefully the bat
not the hand
he was trying to get out of the way and
i'm hoping jeff as he released the bat
that took away some of that
impact
gallon wasn't trying to hit him he was
just trying to pitch him inside and the
crowd happy that acuna will take his
place at first base
came back in there with that fastball
and struck him out
right there with a fastball ozuna caught
looking
obviously expecting some kind of a
breaking pitch or something off speed
out of the zone ends up taking a 94 mile
an hour for seymour surprising thing
with albie's has been that he has
developed that power pitch hit on the
ground to the right side over is the
second baseman throw into first
is van meter and the inning is over well
gallon pitches around the lead off hit
by pitch leaves a man we've played one
d-back's nothing atlanta nothing
in there against the righty wilson at a
buck 72 and two home runs
[Music]
[Applause]
and he threw it away van meter will move
up to second he might get third here
he's going to take the turn albies has
to chase it down and josh is standing at
third base
a costly two base error there for the
pitcher bryce wilson
steven vogt hits one high in the air
right field and it's gone
stephen vogt makes it two nothing
diamondbacks
that is just a batting practice fastball
right down the middle of the plate
with that walk to nick heath the
diamondbacks once again lead the majors
in base on balls with 96 league averages
only 67. here we go again and heath can
fly he'll stop at second this time as
wilson throws another one away only
played five home games
so far on the year another 3-2 pitch for
smith and he got him to swing and miss
he comes two two that's what you call
this swing and a miss
radius swings through a fastball
that's at number two already three
strikeouts for gallon there's two w d
maximum
he narrowly missed a home run hitting it
high off the bricks and right down the
line
old calhoun gets it up in the air see
you later
cole calhoun
it's three nothing diamondbacks well the
lefties are doing some damage calhoun
again
this time 105 miles an hour off the bat
and he clubbed that one with a no doubt
about it three-nothing d-back zac gallon
will face nine one and two
hit batter and a walk that's all he's
allowed so far
popped up
does the splits at the plate as it's
altered three first made side smith
staggering makes the catch just in the
fair territory two outs okay didn't even
bother running
going back down there
what a play josh van meters got it and
gallon works it one two three third
and that's more like it
ball had some tilt to it votes swung
over the top he's struck out
nick heath no balls two strikes
did he go
yes he did and wilson with a high heat
takes care of the arizona center fielder
no runs a hit nobody left home fourth
coming up
that zach gallon has walked a man he's
hit a batter and he's fan four here's
the pitch from gallon so i get a miss
chase a curveball boat drops it picks it
up throws to first strikeout number five
boy nice pitch that time the breaking
ball and he was just had no idea how to
hit this pitch two outs here's dansby
swanson
one-on-one is lifted out to left center
nickith has got it
nick heath go get it
what a play in center watch your molars
nick heath a spectacular diving catch to
end the bottom of the fourth in atlanta
went out for stephen smith
got a fastball and hits it deep to right
field pavon smith hits off the wall and
that rolls back toward the infield
pavon's headed for third pavon smith is
in there standing up with a triple off
the wall
escobar six homers 12 knocked in in his
last 14 games
base hit
maven smith as whole make it four
nothing the rbi for escobar he backs in
the fifth with one out go triple walk
single two outs here's van meter
four-nothing d-backs love to get one
more across here
up the middle and throw that's a base
hit
here comes cole calhoun and escobar
stops at third
and it's five nothing diamondbacks
we go to the bottom of the fifth zach
gallon back to work comes the one-two to
jackson swinging a miss no chance that a
curveball bounces away from vote bare
hands throws to first to complete the
put out and now gallon has set down 10
in a row
he hasn't allowed a hit through five
five innings of no hit baseball so far
gallon has retired 15 of the 17 he has
faced
and freeman shoots one into shallow
right center heath coming on
cole calhoun can't get there either
there's the first braves hit
freddy freeman comes through and
atlanta's got it at the corners with one
out so they're at the corners now with
one out
marcel ozuna five nothing diamondbacks a
pitch mizuna hits it on the ground to
third backhanded by escobar second for
one on to first five four three double
play inning over 12 of 18 outs recorded
on three or fewer pitches 74 pitches
through six scoreless for galin
did he go
yes he did
vic carapaza rings up the pan to that
strikeout number six for gallon
this would count as the first ever
career complete game and shutout for
zach
this is his 30th career start
and he's on his way heath in center
calls off calhoun d-backs win it
five-nothing
gallon gets the complete game shutout
one hitter
and the diamondbacks
get another win on this road trip they
are rolling along with one more to go d
backs on the trip now six and three